kommen wir jetzt mal zu einer wirklich
sehr sehr wichtigen frage die mich super
viele menschen gefragt habe auch über
instagram haben wir leute geschrieben
jedoch dagegen vor und so was geht ab
und jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht's gut weg ist auch wirklich sehr
gut die woche war echt cool vor allem
wegen einem ja enorm coolen feedback
also ich muss sagen die letzte woche war
auf jeden fall so was ich jetzt gewöhnt
bin oder generell so die feedback
stärkste woche was mich wirklich sehr
gefreut hat alle die es nicht wissen ich
habe am letzten dienstag oder so ein
video hochgeladen
da ging es um den fernsehbeitrag über
mich wo ich halt so ein bisschen
schlecht dargestellt wurde und da bin
ich halt ein bisschen darauf eingegangen
und das feedback war wirklich extrem
krass also viel viel mehr als das was
ich erwartet habe
wir haben so viele leute auch privat
oder bei instagram beschrieben auch
wirklich viele bekannte leute die halt
ja auch in dieser position sind oder so
videoblogger influenza was wir machen ja
da wollte ich jetzt einfach mal kurz die
chance genutzt um dafür danke zu sagen
also wirklich den vielen dank an alle
die extrem lange texte geschrieben haben
hier ist verbreitet haben und so weiter
ja danke ich muss jetzt auch sagen
eigentlich war die sache mit diesem
video für mich halt komplett gegessen
wobei ich wie schon gesagt ich hätte
niemals gedacht das ist noch mal so eine
krasse welle auslösen ich habe selbst
viele kommentare bekommen und es gibt
noch viele sachen die ja so ein bisschen
offen stehen und da habe ich mir gedacht
ich hab schon ewigkeiten fragen und
antworten video mehr gemacht ich mache
jetzt einfach mal wieder so ein leichtes
fragen und antworten video allerdings
alles noch mal auf dieses thema bezogen
und dann sollte eigentlich alles erklärt
seien an die das video jetzt schon nicht
gesehen haben ich verlinke ich das erst
mal ganz oben im video beschreibung
schaut euch das erst mal an und dann
wieder das video weil sonst macht es
eigentlich nicht so sind ich habe mir
eine menge kommentare rausgesucht
darunter auch viele fragen waren
meistens also top kommentare die die
anscheinend wichtigsten fragen die habt
so verallgemeinern oder schön
zusammengefasst haben darunter wie schon
gesagt auch sehr viele große bekannte
youtube motorrad kommentiert sami
slimani habe ich gerade gesehen jonas
hey moritz skl show die dann noch ein
paar use also wirklich einem danke die
schauen wir uns mal zusammen an nicht zu
vergessen mal wanne
margaux ewig aber das war jetzt längst
auch noch nicht anfang an mit dem ersten
kommentar von michelle danzinger sie
schreibt wo wir fehlen gerade wirklich
die worte ich werde von sequenz zur
sequenz aggressiver und um ehrlich zu
sein fassungslos leider fällt mir das in
letzter zeit immer stärker auf dass die
herkömmlichen medien in fenster
belächeln und ihnen ihren erfolg nicht
gönnen
aber das kommt noch mal alles tut mir
echt leid für dich dass dir das passiert
ist was ich auch mal sagen muss mir kam
es so vor als würden die meisten leute
die das schauen das noch mal als viel
heftiger waren als ich also ich hab es
natürlich schon so ich war jetzt ein
bisschen habe ich ja schon gesagt ein
bisschen sauer oder traurig darüber
aber was manche in den kommentaren
ausgedrückt haben hat meine emotionen
noch einmal deutlich übertroffen was ich
natürlich gar nicht schlecht finde aber
ich hätte niemals gedacht der youtuber
ewig schöne grüße an nicht geschrieben
hinterhältige war damals bei der es der
ist genauso die lutschen die einen aber
dann hinter deinem rücken lachen die
dich aus gut dass du dein studium
durchziehen system wichtigsten allein
schon damit hast du die gebracht die tun
so als wärst du nur youtuber junge du
bist akademiker die sollen sich mal
selber also habe ich mich auch wirklich
sehr darüber gefreut über den kommentar
das wurde ja leider in dem beitrag nicht
wirklich thematisiert dass ich auch
studieren gut aber so ist das also ich
muss auch ehrlich sagen ich hätte
niemals gedacht ich realisiert dass
eigentlich auch jetzt oder habe es in
dieser woche richtig realisiert was das
für drecks beitrag war und fragte mich
wie ich das thema so vor einem jahr
einfach so schnell abgehakt habe keine
ahnung torge kommentiert herr alex ich
habe das damals live gesehen und war
unglaublich würde diese arroganz das
fernsehen oftmals hat ist wirklich nur
zum ärgern
wir sollten uns bewusst machen und ich
denke dann werden wir auch die sein die
zuletzt lachen fernsehen schauen immer
weniger menschen online wird mehr und
mehr außerdem wenn wir etwas produzieren
kostet es ein minimum von dem was das
fernsehen braucht um einige millionen an
den bildschirm zu locken
ich glaube wir sollten uns alle
entspannen denn wir sind die die am ende
noch
da sind ich denke hat es so gemeint das
nicht jetzt nur die youtuber noch da
sind sondern halt der ganze online
bereich oder die ganzen onlinemedien
über den kommentar ich mich auch
wirklich sehr gefreut ich habe hier noch
angepinnt die einzige sache die ich dazu
noch ergänzen kann weil ich studie auch
ungefähr so den bereich und ich lerne
auch viel über sich ich habe ja in dem
video schon gesagt dass online medien
natürlich immer noch eine klare
steigerung verweisen und das fernsehen
und print bereich ein bisschen runter
geht ich bin aber der festen überzeugung
dass das fernsehen auf jeden fall noch
sehr sehr sehr sehr lange bestehen
bleibt weil es gibt einige sachen die
sind ohne das fernsehen gar nicht so
wirklich umzusetzen sei es jetzt eine
fußball-wm oder ein live konzert also
solche sachen die locken hat im
fernsehen millionen von zuschauern vor
die glotze und ich meine es halt megane
spannen sich auf die couch zu setzen und
fernseher anzumachen und wm zu gucken so
kann ich es zumindest auch
nachvollziehen würde ich mir ungern im
internet angucken wobei man dann
natürlich auch sagen kann smardtv und so
weiter vielleicht für die fußball wm im
jahr 2028 auch ein smart tv über das
internet geschaut kann natürlich sein
sind aber alles nur theorien ich meine
öffentlich rechtliche sender wie das zdf
vor der ard wdr und so weiter werden ja
durch den rundfunkbeitrag finanziert und
dieses system erst mal auszuschalten
also ich denke mal das dauert noch es
gehört geschrieben da hat wohl jemand
angst in fünf jahren nicht mehr von der
gebührenfinanzierten s-klasse renz viel
zu teure fernsehstudio gefahren zu
werden weil ich auch lust sich den
kommentar wobei ich halte die gerade
schon gesagt nicht davon ausgehe dass
natürlich leider ja ich guck auch
überhaupt kein zdf oder ard wirklich nur
sehr selten für sport event oder sonst
was ja ich bin halt der meinung dass das
sich noch ein bisschen länger hinzieht
haben jetzt mal zu einer wirklich sehr
sehr wichtigen frage die mich super
viele menschen gefragt habe auch über
instagram haben wir leute geschrieben
jedoch dagegen vor und so ich habe jetzt
gerade noch den kommentar von sami
slimani gelesen und zwar hat er
geschrieben ich habe den beitrag erst im
rahmen eines videos gesehen
unglaublich wie dargestellt wurde ist
alter kann man dagegen nicht vorgehen
das sind einfach verbitterte menschen
aus der fernsehbranche die nicht damit
klar kommen dass eine neue generation
der filmemacher entsteht auch bezogen da
noch dieser kommentar könntest du nicht
wegen übler nachrede anzeigen ihr
könntest du dir nicht wegen übler
nachrede anzeigen worauf ich dann noch
diese antwort unter den kommentar auch
gern drei nehmen will
und zwar ja ich glaube verleumdung oder
so nennt sich das und dadurch dass das
zwei millionen leute sehen kann sie
dadurch auch schon ins gefängnis kommt
statements also wir haben wirklich ultra
viele leute geschrieben jedoch dagegen
rechtlich vor zeigt doch den sender an
oder sonst war ich bin jetzt natürlich
auch kein medienanwalt hatte aber
letztens noch das war in der uni also
ich studiere eigentlich genau das
richtige für dieses thema jetzt
natürlich kann ich jetzt nicht zu 100
prozent in die tiefe gehen das
fachwissen habe ich einfach nicht aber
wenn man jetzt mal alle aussagen die
halt getroffen wurde in dem beitrag raus
nimmt dann lässt sich davon wirklich
sehr wenig ja unter üblen nachrede
fasten würde ich mal schätzen in
deutschland ist ja meinungsfreiheit und
wenn die redaktion dieser sendung halt
diese meinung darüber hat dann kann man
ist auch gut dass meinungsfreiheit ist
also sollte es jetzt nicht rüberkommen
aber wenn diese meinung halt so ist dann
ist deren meinung so und nur weil ich
jetzt sage das fernsehen ist oder die
talkshow dunja hayali ist die finde ich
auch nicht unbedingt jetzt nur auf den
beitrag bezogen kann ich wirklich nicht
viel mit anfangen mit seinem talk runden
zeug aber es ist halt meine meinung und
das kann mir niemand nehmen
das einzige wo ist meine meinung nach
kritisch werden könnte ist die hat
gesagt dass ich meine sache nicht kennen
zeichner und schleicht darum mache was
überhaupt nicht der fall ist also das
habe ich noch nie gemacht und das ist
einfach falsch und das kann man auch so
überlegen mit beispielen wenn ich jetzt
aber dann sagen würde ja jetzt klage
gegen den sender so prozesse mit
fernsehsendern bänder jetzt über üble
nachrede oder ja einfach falsche aussage
ich weiß nicht wie es fachlich heißt
wenn das halt vorliegt und man den
sender anzeigt oder gegen klar es dauert
halt erstens übertrieben lange bis
damals das urteil gefällt wird zumindest
ist das meistens so und es kostet eine
menge geld das zdf hat sicherlich auch
eine sehr gute rechtsabteilung und wenn
ich das verlieren würde ist mir das
fünf- bis zehntausend euro auf keinen
fall wert und ich mein mit diesem video
habe ich jetzt schon eigentlich alles
erreicht was ich mir erträumt hat damit
zu erreichen ich bin mir sicher dass
haben eine menge der verantwortlichen
leute gesehen
ich habe zwar keine nachricht von
irgendwem bekommen der dafür
verantwortlich ist aber trotzdem bin ich
mir sicher dass es so gewesen ist und
deswegen ist alles
super und ich kann mich entspannt
zurücklehnen und die sache mit dem
gefängnis hat das stufe ich als sehr
unwahrscheinlich
hey moritz kommentiert du hast echt wir
sind echt wir sind alle eine hut also
die aussage ist wirklich stimmt muss man
auch ganz ehrlich so sagen die youtuber
stellen sich hin und sagen du bist echt
ey du bist auch echt wir sind cool
miteinander so ist wirklich eine super
aussage was nur komplett dagegen spricht
ist das ist ja wirklich andauernd irgend
einen dummen brief gibt und sich extrem
viele youtuber gar nicht mögen ja das
weiß ich auch aus internen quellen ich
meine ich bin ja selber youtube naja gut
vielleicht mal zum schluss auch den
kommentar von jody mit ryan sie hat
geschrieben hätte so gerne bei dieser
tag und tag runde hätte so gerne bei
dieser tour grunde gesessen und
angefangen mit dieser frau zu
diskutieren angefangen mit der frage was
die dann macht jetzt wo sie seit 1998
nicht mehr relevant ist und keiner sie
mehr als moderatorin buchen wird
irgendwann auch für die gute hat neben
ihrer arbeit noch ein studium absolviert
sollte ja eigentlich drin sein
moderieren ist ja auch nicht so
anstrengend war gutes video alex danke
ja ich finde damit kann ich dieses video
auf jeden fall schön rund abschließen
ich meine ich bin sogar der festen
überzeugung ich habe auch schon einige
fernsehsendungen live gesehen wie die
halt produziert werden also ich sags im
studio und die moderatoren bekommen halt
im text vorgelegt da steht er sogar auf
dem fernseher und dann läuft das sondern
grüner strich lang immer wo die grad
sind und mehr müssen die nicht macht und
also ganz wichtig immer auch erst an die
eigene nase fassen ich hoffe dieses
video an euch gefallen und lass mir
gerne doch noch um da steckt das letzte
video ab ich habe letztes mal einen
burger laden mit einem meiner stern
bewertung getestet das war nicht
vergessen
haut rein